يعني يعني كل الجهات الفاعله على الارض
اعلنت هذه المنطقه منطقه منكوبه لعده
اسباب اولا يعني حجم الاضرار تفوق
الامكانات المحليه لاحتوائها او التعامل
مع هذه
الكارثه يعني صباحا مبكرا عندما كان هناك
اداه استغاثه من الاحياء ومن الحارات
والبلدات يعني منظمات الدفاع المدني توجهت
لانتشال ونقل الجثث الى المشافي وايضا
الطاقم الطبيه لكن بامكانيات محليه وبسيطه
اضافه الى يعني المعدات والامكانيات لا
توجد خبره للتعامل مع مثل هذه
الازمات في الجانب الاداري حتى
وايضا نوعيه الاصابات خاصه نحن نتحدث عن
مئات الجرحى نوعيه الاصابات يعني التخصصات
الطبيه غير قادره على التعامل معها يعني
كنا نسمع من مشفى عفرين العسكري بان معظم
الاص اصابات كسور في العظام وفي الجمجمه
وبالتالي لربما هناك طبيب عظميه او طبيب
بين في المنطقه وبالتالي
يقوم الممرضون والاطباء غير الاطباء يعني
غير اختصاصين بالتعامل مع حالات صعبه
ومعقده تستدعي جراحات
فوريه وبالتالي هذه المنطقه تحتاج الى
يعني اطقم طبيه تحتاج الى معدات تحتاج الى
اغاثه مباشره لانه عدد كبير من الناس
فقدوا منازلهم واصبحوا بدون
[موسيقى]
نتحدث عن يعني منخفض الجوي قاسي وبرد شديد
من مستوى الامراض وايضا يزيد من مستوى
معاناه الناس في هذه المنطقه